[Musique]
ça va taper dur jusqu'à mi avril ce sont
les mots d' emmanuel macron que rapporte
le maire de poissy
on a une situation de tension qui est
elle en ile de france on ne peut pas ne
pas aller plus loin par rapport aux
décisions qui ont déjà été prises la
spécificité de l'île de france
n'encourage pas
un confinement
le week-end j'ai pas de préparer les
esprits s'agit de suivre je dirais jour
par jour heure par heure l'évolution de
ces conditions sanitaires et la
situation s'aggrave en particulier dans
ces deux régions dans ses seize
départements de nouvelles mesures de
freinage massive de l'épidémie
interviendront à compter de ce vendredi
soir minuit et pour quatre semaines
mais cet arrêt public tape fort il avait
déjà tapé fort sur le social sur
l'économie que les français sont
matraqués qui ont fermé samedi et
dimanche
je pense qu'on s'attend à une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires de plus de 40 %
donc on va travailler pour payer le
fournisseur c'est tout à partir de
vendredi et pour quatre semaines
confinement 7 sur 7
en ile de france haute france
alpes-maritimes eure seine-maritime et
que les commerces de première nécessité
ou vers les lycées passe en demis
georges activités extérieures comme le
sport et les balades autorisé sans
limite de temps on n'est pas des bêtes à
travailler du lundi jusqu'à 18 heures au
vendredi et pas sortir le week-end enfin
de lait par an on n'est pas des bêtes on
n'est pas des chiens n'est pas dans des
zones déjà parce qu'elle prouve une
scène qu'on croirait d'un autre temps
depuis une dizaine de jours les
israëliens on retrouve une vie
incroyablement normale ne faisons pas
semblant de ne pas voir qu'aujourd'hui
la difficulté que nous avons c'est à la
fois le virus est le fait qu emmanuel
macron aura tout ce qu'il entreprend
pour toute la france cette fois ci le
couvre-feu l'heure est modifié il passe
à 19 heures dès ce samedi profitant
librement des espaces extérieurs
mais soyons hyper rigoureux pour
proscrire les regroupements privé ou
dans l'espace public
quatre jours de suspension de doute de
crainte partiellement levé ce soir le
vaccin astrazeneca sera à nouveau
disponible en france dès demain après
midi
il s'agit d'un vaccin sûr et efficace
ces avantages en matière de protection
des personnes contre le prophète 19
sachant les risques associés en matière
de
totalisation dépasse les riches et ans
en réunion ou les non blancs ne sont pas
lui il est blanc ne sont pas illimitées
ça mais je mens et déjà à dose unique et
donc ça existe mais je viens de vous
expliquer que ça existe quand vous avez
des jean jacques bourdin par exemple des
femmes qui subissent des violences
sexistes nous sexuelle quand vous avez
des personnes de couleur qui subissent
parce que de couleurs des
discriminations parfois ces personnes
ont envie de se retrouver entre elles
pour pouvoir en discuter et il s'agit
pas de faire du tri entre les personnes
vous avez une segmentation en fonction
de la couleur de peau
si on le faisait pour une autre couleur
de peau que les blancs tout le monde
hurle au racisme moi je vais vous dire
ce que je fais quand je suis dans la
merde c'est à dire que j'essaye de
trouver la vannière doit sortir elle a
plus le plus souvent cette année dans la
vérité déclarations chocs du président
américain à l'encontre du président
russe
pensez vous que c'est un tueur ou oui
alors qu'elle paris doit-il payer le
prix qu'il paiera le connais très
bientôt et russes crient vraiment au
scandale le président de la chambre
basse du parlement qui est un proche de
poutine dénonce l' hystérie de joe biden
ils nous insultent attaqué poutine en le
traitant le tueur c'est une attaque
contre notre pays
quant à la conversation a commencé je
lui ai dit je vous connais et vous me
connaissez cij établi que cela s'est
produit alors soyez prêts